recall when we were examining the motion
of an object in two dimensions we
introduced a Cartesian coordinate and a
position vector now let's suppose the
object has moved to a new point along
the orbit
well we'll write another vector R of T
and let's say this took a time delta T
to the new point and what we want to
define is the displacement of that
object so that's a vector Delta R and
recall that a vector at time a T plus
delta T is equal to the old vector R of
T plus this displacement vector Delta R
now what we want to consider is a limit
as delta T goes to zero and let's just
look graphically at what that means as
we move this delta delta T as delta T
gets smaller and smaller and our object
is getting closer and closer to its
position at time T and the position
vector R at T plus delta T is getting
closer and closer to R of T delta T the
key fact is that if we do a tangent to
the orbit then the limit of Delta R is
approaching tangent to the curve so in
the limit Delta R the direction is
tangent to the orbit so that's our first
key property of Delta R now the second
thing we wanted to express is if we
write Delta R as a displacement in the I
hat direction and a displacement in the
J hat direction now again maybe we can
just clean this up a little bit and see
what we mean by that so here's our Delta
R
and we have a little Delta X in this
direction Delta Y in that direction
remember Delta X or Delta Y can be
positive or negative that's alright
now if we wanted to find our velocity as
the limit as delta T goes to 0 of Delta
R over delta T then what we see is we
have two pieces the limit as delta T
goes to 0 of 2 Delta x over delta T I
hat plus the limit as delta T goes to 0
of delta y delta T J hat and the
definition of these limits will write
that as the derivative dr DT so the
velocity is dr DT and that's equal to DX
DT how that coordinate function is
changing in time I hat plus dy DT J hat
now as far as notation goes we write
this velocity as an X X component of the
velocity plus a Y component of the
velocity where the X component VX is DX
DT and the Y component is dy DT now
recall that the direction was tangent to
the curve but the magnitude of the
velocity what we call the speed is just
the sum of the squares of the components
the square root and so now we've just
described what we refer to as the
instantaneous velocity
so far we looked at a trajectory in two
dimensions let's again consider some
type of motion where we choose a
positive y-axis a positive x-axis in
origin unit vectors I hat in J hat and
we'll have some type of trajectory where
our object is moving like that we know
that at this particular time the
velocity is tangent to this trajectory
at that point and now what we'd like to
do is try to describe we've described
its two components the X and V Y as a
vector so if he did vector decomposition
we would write a vector like this in a
vector like that this is the X component
that's the Y component and now if I
define this angle theta we know that a
vector has a direction and a magnitude
we've seen that we call the magnitude
the speed so that's just the sum of
these components squared square root
speed is always positive so we always
take the positive square root and now
what about the direction of this vector
in the XY plane
well we can see from our geometry that
the tangent theta is given by the Y
component over the X component or one
could say that the angle theta
I think this given time is the inverse
function of B Y over VX and so now we've
described not only the direction of the
velocity but the angle that it's making
with the horizontal axis and so we've
now completely described the velocity
instantaneous velocity vector at time T
in terms of its two component functions
its speed and the angle that it makes
with the positive x-axis